hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don sockin today we're sitting
down with Blake quarter hello howdy
thank you for joining us it's a real
pleasure we're at COFA the Congress on
the future of engineering software we're
on day two ish three ish now and this is
our second conversation after ping foo
so I'm really excited to talk to you
Blake is the head of software developer
research at Stratasys he's been to for
years now
and previously at Oh was it open get a
grab can grab CAD and soul or was part
of the team that sold that about six
years ago now well four years ago but
six years ago you started it so you were
working on it so so I was not a founder
of grab cat I joined the team relatively
early to help them build their first
commercial product yes and then it was
really it was hard II may bomb and john
stephenson who really led the initiative
to to transition it to make the
difference in additive manufacturing and
that's what we're gonna be talking about
what are we talking about additive
manufacturing 3d printing or gonna be
talking about the impact that that has
on the world in all of the different
ways and then we'll maybe jump into some
simulation questions at the end so tell
us a little bit about the life journey
what kind of got you into cuz you are
Princeton what got you into even
engineering the first place and then
into 3d printing cave done your research
apparently not it was so many things you
know I it that I started I went into an
engineering school because at Princeton
it's an extra thing to apply for and I
wasn't sure whether I went to studied
math or engineering and I fit in and so
the obvious thing was to you know apply
for the one that will get you both and
pretty early on I unfortunately got
turned off from math I had a phenomenal
professor but I didn't I didn't like the
subject matter and and I ended up really
enjoying engineering design I was
starting to use CAD I deployed pro
engineer there and found it to be
fascinating and I and I was also really
enjoying programming computer graphics
so once once I saw a pro engineer
I the only job I applied for was was PTC
it was they were the leaders at the time
and so that's what I started in the
industry I was at PTC for six years I
had a good career started as a sales
engineer working life through product
management I was running business
development for the mechanical division
when I left and the reason I left was
PTC does amazing things there there's
still a great company but I found I I
wanted to solve some very specific
problems in geometric modeling to make
to make CAD systems more available what
we found was that that that generation
of CAD tools was really needed to be
used by dedicated trained folks and I
thought everyone should be able to
express their ideas in 3d and work with
the 3d information sort of some people
might use the awkward work
democratization you talk about this in
and there'd been some inspiration
there's a product called Sketchup that
was on the market that there was an
architectural practice showed there was
a way a much much easier paradigm and we
we wanted to make that available for
precise solid models like the mechanical
industry needs so I started that company
and after a little while I hired a guy
by the name of I started with David
Taylor who's another phenomenal guy in
the industry Mike Payne became our first
CEO and made the product real and then
guy by the name of Chris Randall's all
these folks have been to Coe Fez became
the second CEO or I guess the third CEO
after me to to make it commercially
successful and that was acquired by
ANSYS so that was about a ten year
journey for me startups have ups and
downs they're not for the fate in the
heart I learned a lot of lessons the
hard way yeah but I also learned a lot
of really incredibly important skills
and made a lot of connections during
that time and one thing I didn't realize
is that just repeating a message
tirelessly that you really believe in it
takes a long time or it feels like a
long time but you changed the way people
think and I feel like the contribution I
was able to make there in that phase of
my life
was the industry said wait a minute we
do need to make these tools either
easier and every CAD vendor did work in
that direction so the whole industry
moved just because we thought you know
we had this one little idea
and I think that the that I think that
wave was kind of run its course but it I
think that's it was it I that's the
first time I was though that I really
was able to create an impact and it look
is the big deal is it earth-shattering
more people who do solid modeling it's
it's fun and commercially important but
but for me I think you know help people
go home as either their kids a little
bit earlier you know less frustration
with these little things that you've
gotten frustrated software makes your
blood boil a little bit just taking some
of that away you know yeah people's
quality of life is a learning curve
there's so many important things to do
yeah in this process so so so space
claim was I put about 10 years into
space claim and I think that I believe
you only get one shot at this thing and
so I think it's enough of life to put
into one project and so I ended up
moving on to grab CAD
because those guys were doing something
really amazing they had created a
community of Mechanical Engineers and it
turns out there there's a subpoena new
for folk mechanical engineers is a
creative activity people create things
and they want to share them and we just
created a place where people could share
what they do and talk to each other
community it's a community of mechanical
CAD users and there there's just amazing
need for it and once you have one of
those everyone comes to it so it's like
the LinkedIn for mechanical design nice
and I I was actually one of the first
members on the site I was so excited
about it myself
good and and then when I had the
opportunity to join the company to build
a first commercial product it was it was
it was amazing to join John and Hardy it
was amazing to join a company that had a
very different kind of culture from from
the other companies I'd work for and he
learned a kind of totally different way
of thinking about what a business is and
what products are even to some extent
and so we ended up making collaboration
tools for engineers that are kind of
like what we would call an industry PDM
systems data management systems but
maybe them fun online
nowadays this seems kind of obvious but
the idea of doing it like Google
Hangouts barely existed when we got
started we were the first that was the
first product that had a precise solid
modeling kernel on the cloud that you
can do precise measurements on model so
we built this awesome data management
tool and then something really
funny happened Stratasys and i deeply
deeply admire the leaders of stratasys
for making this decision I think it's
surreal challenge they said hey our
industry to make our 3d printers more
more more available to sort of to do to
do more things with them we need better
software applications and also the
company happened have been sort of five
different startups that had kind of
merged together but never really
integrate and they knew they needed to
integrate I think they've been putting
office said we're gonna integrate the
company through software now you know
the there are a couple there's some
challenges with with a story like that
you have a new team that has to go
around meet all these people but it was
it was a wonderful experience of Stratos
has welcomed us in a team of us went to
every site we learned about their
problems we told them about what we did
and we formed a new organization a new
software organization so grabbed CAD was
able to be the conversational platform
within stratasys done it up uniting the
different teams exactly we had we we
were good at multi-site collaboration
grab CAD was founded in Estonia we had
our headquarters moved to Boston we also
had a site in Cambridge England which is
a good place to have a CAD team and we
had a really this this this this network
of both sort of IT experts on the cloud
side and CAD experts it's a really good
team john stephenson put together a
phenomenal team and this seems like a
really important essence to any
community that's being built in whatever
industry is if there's a missing piece
of community then you'll not you won't
actually be able to maximize the
potential of the software or the tools
that you're trying to build or the
impact that you're trying to make or
people actually using that to build
things there's all these aspects of
communication that have to come into
play and having a community platform
within software especially 3d printing
software is so important all the
different ones that exist out there so
are they now able to communicate with
one another
certain 3d printing software with other
3d printing software can they
communicate can different CAD models now
CAD platforms communicate as well that's
exactly what we did so so yes so we sort
of took our what stratasys did is they
took the grab CAD culture
and they allowed us to sort of broadcast
that wider in the organization so we
could bring in that all the other
software teams around and a business has
evolved and changed and we ended up
focusing on some things other than other
things but we we created an integrated
platform that supports all of our
printing technologies and probably more
importantly we improved access by today
you have to go through a kind of
cumbersome process or you had to where
you would export weird clunky formats
that are outdated and then bring them in
and lose a lot of information and we
started working with CAD vendors and
partners to directly read the cad
information in a much higher fidelity
way removing some awkward steps so we've
come up with a much smoother process
where you can work with your precise CAD
parts and you kind of get the results
you expect and then so what is Stratasys
then right now what would you call it
the largest additive manufacturing large
3d printing company and what's the
difference between 3d printing and
additive manufacturing so I'm not a
marketing person I stratasys is probably
the the leader in polymer additive
manufacturing plastics plastics and we
also have a large one of the largest
service bureaus the global service
bureau where we have all the all all
normal additive manufacturing
technologists even some subtractive so
we make a lot of parts we ship a lot of
parts in addition to making the machines
that make make parts so you make some
machines that make parts and then you
also make parts yeah and when you make
them you make them normally throughout
history we've made them in a way that
you would take one gigantic hunk of
metal or whatever material it is and
then you would carve out the piece that
you need and that would be subtractive
manufacturing exactly as you're taking
those corners or whatever pieces away
and then you're scrapping them and
recycling them and then there's the
additive manufacturing which is where
you just make the one piece that you
need over and over again so there's no
scraps I need to be subtracted every
single time yeah I mean yes exactly
additive yeah you waste less material in
in most processes but producing that
material
maybe a little more complicated and
because you have to make a mold every
single time is that true or you can 3d
print it where you don't need a mold but
you need just the CAD file that enables
you to print in that three-dimensional
space without a mold but the mold is
kind of a CAD file well that's actually
a really good example I mean we just
take a simple normal sort of plastic
part like the case for your phone or
something like that you're gonna have to
at least two pieces of Steel that come
together so you have to get these pieces
of steel you gotta machine them and
that's a lot of stuff and those things
cost you know in the thousands to tens
of thousands of dollars for small ones
and then you're gonna shoot plastic into
them over and over again to get parts
out and that's relatively inexpensive
but there's a huge initial cost and a
lot of wasted material so if you just
want one or two parts that's not
practical with 3d printing or additive
manufacturing you just get the part you
want sometimes we print some support
structures or some other sort of
scaffolding and to make it possible but
it's it's a much more efficient process
and so for different parts and different
technologies you're gonna have some
trade-off curve for for quantity I'm you
also asked about the difference between
3d printing and additive manufacturing
that's really a matter of taste
I think that 3d printing is usually
refers to the more consumer type fun
MakerBot like 3d printers that just you
know think you see in schools and and
it's just sort of it kind of refers to
the low end of the market and additive
manufacturing tends to refer to the high
end and there's a lot that comes along
with that process management quality
control the concept of things like
allowables which means how many of the
ones you make are allowed to be bad
you know for aerospace parts you know
with you know there's a lot of
requirements around that and the the
initial applications an additive
manufacturing really at the high end we
see an aerospace defense an automotive
because that's kind of the nature of it
of the industry okay so the most
applications right now in the additive
manufacturing industry are in aerospace
and automotive the the ones that have
the most rigor around the part creation
you know when you fly on an airplane you
want it to break yeah and and and the
the FAA has these regulations that say
what you're allowed to do to put parts
on airplanes and the quality standards
are significant airframe data for
example you need to dumb it you need to
be able to read that data for a hundred
years that's a kind of mystery Computers
didn't exist a hundred years ago yet
people have you know so so so they're
great challenges and making sure that we
can build airplanes safely and I'm I'm
thrilled that with our FDM technology we
can produce these parts out of a very
fancy material called Ultem 985 with FDU
deposition so the type of 3d printers
that have a little nozzle like like the
low end ones you see are we invented the
technology Scott Crump founded stratasys
with that technology twenty or so years
ago roughly so the nozzle that comes and
builds it out from the bottom
pew pew pew pewpew upwards yeah for
anyone who's ever seen a 3d printer it's
highly likely you saw that one that's
FDM or sometimes they call FFF where it
extrudes just a single bead so our FDA
machines are just like like like they're
way more than MakerBot's on steroids
they're they they there's a lot of
process stuff control stuff that makes
sure that when you're making a part
you're making the part you think you're
going to make and for us we the first
uses of three bringing additive
manufacturing were and prototyping I
have this idea and the computer I want
to hold it in my hands we're going to
make a shape very quickly where we're
focused right now is is is evolving that
technology to where we're making the
best parts possible not the shape as
fast as possible okay and are we running
a you said for example with flight takes
a hundred years sometimes I testing to
be able to know whether or not the part
is most efficient for its what we're
trying to use it for so then are you
running simulations on all these
different types of parts so oh we want
to augment a airplane wing or the
airplane engine or the airplane nose or
whatever aspect of the plane or the
automotive or whatever then you put that
in simulations for a period
it does a hundred flights a month or
whatever and then that's how you knew
that goes on for a hundred years and
then you try and see when does that part
break down why does it break down what
aspect of it breaks down how can we
secure it so that it doesn't break down
so do you do that in the in the testing
as well and the simulating of these
parts that is actually one of my
projects right now so personally I'm
invested in working on some of that the
reality is is that we haven't quite
achieved the same kinds of tools that
we've seen for other manufacturing
processes the additive parts have a lot
of a lot of detail inside of them we're
and we can make micro structures and
lattices that have very specific
material properties the tools that have
traditionally evolved to to simulate the
behavior of solid parts or sheet metal
parts and things like that
don't don't work as well as they should
or was we'd like them to for these kinds
of parts we're making so we're working
with folks at de Sol system the somolia
folks on they've they've been leading
the way of a number new approaches to
simulating this as well as there's a
division of hexagon the MSC division has
a captive company called extreme
engineering where they do phenomenal
work on on homogenizing the material
properties so they can be used by more
traditional solvers the folks at Siemens
as well are working on it for some
composite applications other things
we're doing so we this is a problem
that's bigger than just us and because
the complete these thermoplastics are so
commercially useful there's a lot of
there's a lot of we're working with a
number of folks to achieve the same
competent validation steps for FDM that
you have for other processes that said
there are thousands of FDM parts flying
on airplanes you don't need to be able
to simulate something but it sure helps
so you can do destructive testing you
can you can make a thousand parts and
like okay we know how to make the parts
they work we're gonna trust the
thousands of them one and there are
folks who are very good at managing
those probabilities a lot of aerospace
stuff is managing the probabilities all
right so let's go through from beginning
to where we are now as close as possible
so
we have both the stratasys makes the
machines that print the parts as well as
makes parts and sells those parts now
when you guys have a moment of aha
we are gonna make a better printer for
the parts or we're going to make a
better part when you go through that
process does the team sit down with
designs and engineers and and
collaborate and figure out what's the
best way to make this and then you go
through a series of actual testing
inside of the team inside of your
headquarters or your testing facilities
and you go through a process of
iteration to see if this parts gonna be
able to hold up or if the printers gonna
be able to work well and then and only
then you release that piece or printer
to the world because you know there's a
market demand for it and so that's why
you're making it in the first place as
well so is that generally about how you
guys work yeah I mean you know usually
you perceive a market need and you come
up with some requirements and then you
give that to the engineering team and
they're like we can't do this and
eventually you get to a point where it's
something they can do and it's awesome
and then you take it to market and
hopefully roughly I work on the software
side I could talk a lot about software
engineering I don't know I've watched
with all what the hardware folks do but
I'll tell you a little story about sort
of well I think it's a pretty awesome
thing those guys did so we noticed that
there was that that there was a problem
with with some of the parts that every
once in a while a little bit of plastic
would kind of stick to the head and drop
into the part so you get a little bit of
burnt plastic on your part that doesn't
have as good of material properties yes
the part in that defect is not okay so
we needed to solve that problem and I'm
not sure I can say how we solve that
problem but it was a shockingly simple
mechanical thing like you just got a
from the nozzle that's pointed downward
you just got a cut you have to have
something that just cuts rather than
stop if you stop if you stop it then
it'll drip down and burn that last part
but if you cut it somehow or if you seal
it really tight then maybe we can get it
to prevent that burning that's a you're
alright you're on the right track suits
wrong what the problem
talking about we solved a long time ago
with with with with various different
ways of doing the toolpath and sucking
back the tool the elastic and stuff like
that yeah but but the thing about this
stuff any of that what we had to do to
the thing is that this created a problem
of most parts were okay but the the
variability wasn't wasn't good enough
right we need a certain percentage you
know be basis allowables right roughly
two standard deviations you know that's
what we needed to hit so we were right
at the threshold we knew that if we
could remove those occasional random
defects we would do it and so what the
team engineering team does they
performed a root cause analysis and they
spent a ton of time watching Princeton's
they figure out exactly what was
happening and then they had an idea for
how to fix it maybe more than one but
eventually they were able to demonstrate
that they were solve the problem and
that process probably took a few years
like that was a really deep exploration
with an incredibly simple solution in
the end and so one of the things that
that engineering teams do is rather than
sort of have Furion arguments you
perform a very exhaustive root cause
analysis or to make this tree of
anything that could have gone wrong
until you get to the exact nub of what
it is and then you know exactly what you
have to do be you're successful and I it
was really awesome to watch the team in
our team in Minneapolis do that
definitely yeah and so Minneapolis and
is a real base okay and then on the
software side of things on the software
research side of things
currently what are you because you were
saying that you're part of the part of
your research right now is in
simulations at stratasys but then also
what are these other aspects of software
research where are we going with
software with with in 3d printing well
well the big trends and just just in the
industry so we talked a lot about sort
of validation simulation that's a big
trend yeah there's sort of a the sort of
the back end of that is traceability
monitoring we're recording what's going
on with the machine so one the data's
got to be right but also you have to
make sure the machine is healthy and
it's being serviced properly so there's
a lot around that you
the high-end for those machines there's
a lot going on in terms of like I said
before ease of use where we're trying to
make it more accessible be able to print
directly from your CAD system we're
working with CAD vendors to put tools in
the CAD system so when you're designing
things you can make the most of the
additive technology rather than getting
to the point where you make and you're
like oh that if I just done this a
little bit different to be a much better
part so moving upstream in the design
process right now if you want to you
know take advantage of lattice
structures you when you make parts
you've seen engineering drawings the the
mechanical version of a blueprint they
this type of lattices and we're talking
about what's on the interior yeah of the
object one of the benefits of additive
manufacturing is you can make parts that
vary in density and vary in material
properties the thing is that CAD systems
today for the most part only let you
specify a part of sort of uniform
density and there are some techniques
and tricks you can use can split up into
multiple bodies an insert of label them
with different different information but
then if you want to make a drawing of
that it doesn't come out right it did
but the CAD tools were design and
documentation just haven't quite caught
up with the manufacturing technology and
so they're it's a very interesting
problem because what engineers want to
specify material properties as a
function of space this is where I want
it strong this is where I want it
lightweight maybe you know there are
folks around here talking about things
like oxidic materials which means that
usually when you when you squish
something it squeezes out but instead
it's do squish something and it also
squeezes in oh it's crazy or when you
heat it up it doesn't expand why so so
and there are there are all sorts of
amazing applications of these kinds of
materials so so so we can make these
things and vary it but how do you
explain that and it's simple analogy
like when you print you know you want
print say a purple rectangle and you do
that on a laser printer that laser
printer is using some sort of half
toning or dithering to mix cyan and
magenta to give you the color purple you
asked for what you have to do in
additive manufacturing today is say what
color is a purple can my printer make
I'm going to print all these different
lattice paper in a different halftone
patterns of different cyan and magenta
and see all the different colors and
then sort of a color by number and
figure out which one
it's totally backwards and but before
mechanical injustice I'm making this
part of a 6161 t6 aluminum these are the
mechanical properties when I machine it
is still 6061-t6 aluminum if I did it
right and therefore I know the
properties of it but now it's like just
so kettles haven't really grown up yet
to to be able to have that and quite
frankly we're still developing the
language which with you can specify that
kind of information so we're working
very closely with ki vendors to make
sure the people can describe what they
want to make rather than describing
something that's closed and then sort of
fudging it at the end yeah and it seems
to be a common theme across industry is
that engineers the through them whatever
that has been built with in this case a
3d printer is running off and doing all
these different types of printing for so
many different people but the actual
logging and the trying to figure out how
to make the design tools better and all
that stuff takes a backseat because
everybody's trying to run off with the
technology and use it in all these
different ways similar is happening
across biology and neuroscience and all
these other industries right now let's
talk about biomimicry so yeah so tell us
a little bit about how you guys are
assisting with surgeons and with
cadavers this is interesting stuff yeah
yeah um replacing cadavers yeah so the
so we talked about one of the stresses
as two main product lines and polymers
one is the FDA process we've been
talking about the other is so FDM is a
thermoplastic process where you heat it
up it gets melty and then you cool it
down and you have the same properties
again thermo sets are like epoxy where
it cures once and then when you heat it
up it doesn't melt again and so our
PolyJet machines are incredibly
beautiful and detailed machines that can
create some absolutely gorgeous models
there we do full color printing with
transparency they they create absolutely
gorgeous things the way that works is
there's an industrial inkjet head and it
lays down individual boxes of material
so if you imagine space divided into a
3d grid every cell of that grid gets one
kind of material and these machines can
print eight different materials mm-hmm
and so if you
it's sort of if you buy one of these
machines today it'll have a set of
colors and different resins and you can
do hard and soft and that's kind of cool
um one one project I've been thrilled to
be able to contribute to their human
body option well that's what we've done
so we've come up with a new family of
materials that reproduce the properties
of flesh and bone and also some other
things that you need to do family of
materials so this is like skin and and
whatever is under the skin the next
layer a little more muscle or a little
bit of bone a little bit of it's even
better than that how so the architecture
is very similar to the architecture of
the body if you want to its biomimicry
right so what is our body is made of
cells and those cells combine into
tissues the tissues combine into organs
the organs combine into organ systems
and so that's what we did with bio
mimics we have materials and each voxel
of material is kind of like a cell that
properties and then we have what we call
digital materials which is a dithering
of those across space where we can vary
those material properties so we haven't
announced the details of what these
materials are right now we're not
selling a printer that makes these we're
selling the parts as we're as we're
getting started
oh you're selling the parts not the
printer that makes the cadaver yet well
we're well we do make those but they're
the same printers as we have but when
you sell a printer in a material system
there's a lot of stuff like life cycle
things you know the heads wear out over
time and customers expect to get it you
know so it may be the material I this is
not the case but the kind of thing that
might prevent us from shipping a
material would be that it's wearing out
the head life so we have to do more
development there so the first output of
this project and I who knows what will
come after but the first output is a
couple different kinds of parts
we're specializing in sort of muscle and
bone type anatomies long bone short
bones of doing a lot of work with
vertebra straightening spines and that
kind of thing I explain how that works
and then also blood vessels if you want
to go in and do sort of these things
where you're going into some various
special sort of blood vessels and
practicing that the
they clear em out yeah yeah there's a
bunch of different practices so our
biometrics project is about enabling
doctors to learn how to perform new
surgical operations without requiring
expensive cadaver the goal is to improve
the lower the costs of being able to
learn and deploy new surgical techniques
a good example of that is one of the
first applications is for for for spine
straightening and I'm not a doctor I'll
screw up the medical terminology but
what you do is if someone spine is is
crooked for various reasons you put in
what are called pedicle screws into the
vertebra along serve a vertebra and then
there are titanium rods that the screws
tie into and so the tricky part of the
skill there is the surgeon needs to know
exactly where in the bone to drill and
and there are a couple of operations is
a lot like machining first you drill a
pilot hole then you drill a hole to size
and then you come up with a tap and tap
the threads and then pedicle screws and
there's really cool tools to do all this
stuff but so with so what we had to do
is make a vertebra that's just like it
feels to a surgeon who's performing
performing this mission so the machining
operations on it like the real thing and
so there was all this work we did to to
to make sure that the bone would when
you turn it's just like the real thing
and it's amazing to watch doctors work
on these plastic parts and then give us
feedback on whether it feels real or not
and then we're going back and we're
creating new materials or new more often
patterns and materials these sort of
digital tissues I like to call them to
talk to get it right like when we first
did divert the vertebral stuff they were
really happy with the bones but the
disks we were just doing like with solid
rubber material we hadn't worked on he's
like they're like this is junk they
supposed to be like crab meat crab meat
okay just come out and chunks we're like
okay so we came up with a whole totally
new kind of noisy lattice pattern that
might work and we took it back to them
and like yeah this is great so so we're
working with doctors to figure out how
to take this sort of new family of
materials that have different
squishiness isn't softness either
liquids that can all
have worked together to form these organ
systems this is one of the many nodes in
this space that's moving forward of of
health care so there's all the companies
that are working on printing organs
there's companies that are actual organs
that will work inside your bodies
there's companies that are intuitive
surgical with surgical robots so that
you guys can potentially provide them
with cadavers for surgeons to practice
on it's this is really cool to be able
to digitally print tissue set up a cat's
the file of what you want your cadaver
to look like and over time figure out
the squishiness is the textures of these
tissues what will actually work well for
the specific surgeon on what part of the
body are they operating on I'm really
glad that this is a so it seems to be a
very applicable field and applicable use
of this to an everyday person because
the other stuff about maybe automotive
or aeroplanes seems like it's a little
bit further away from people but even
that is so applicable to us because we
always take cars or planes to places and
that has everything to do with all the
engineers and designers that have to go
through the steps of using software to
test it over time to run simulations on
it to see are we gonna print this are we
gonna sell you a printer that then the
car company will use to print these
pieces or are we gonna print the parts
here and sell it to the car company so
this is a beautiful ecosystem that I
think it needs to be explained even
better for the world to care more about
it 3d printed additive manufacturing
this is probably one of you know I think
it was about five years ago or so that I
was initially like I was saying with the
Apple thing watching the app will be
printed and that was a big aha moment
for me the seeing that this is possible
today now and that was five years ago
and what have we made since then so many
crazy steps forward so I'm really happy
that we're able to sit down times and
there's there is there another aspect of
stratasys that you think would be
important too or another aspect of
additive manufacturing that we should be
aware of
well you know so it's a hot new
technology and whenever you have
something new you know people get
excited about it I think all in all
technologies aren't really good or bad
and yeah we we all want to make the
world a little bit you know leave our
impact on the world and hopefully make
it a little bit better I'm working in
manufacturing there's only so much that
you can do but what I like about
Stratasys is that we're really
connecting to applications that that
that make a difference in products you
know the biomedical stuff kind of has an
obvious impact on people's lives and you
know and and and you know individual
patients that doctors can practice on
that will change lives and it's it's and
that's wonderful to be part of but my
inner inner geek officer really enjoys
the fact that we have gone to a place in
polymer manufacturing where no one else
is gone and I like to think that that
will help people create more efficient
products better solutions use less fuel
and resources even if additive
manufacturing is a little more expensive
up front that we can make better
products and you know I for me as as we
talked before I woke up one morning and
as if as a company we'd become part of
Stratasys and I just want to say I the
Stratasys did a heck of a thing made a
real to bring us in and asked us to work
on these problems and I'm really glad
they did yeah I'm glad too I think the
whole community is glad so maybe you
give us a glimpse what do you think
three five ish down years down the line
maybe even ten years down the line are
we gonna have 3d printers at our houses
or are we going to be still ordering
from companies like Stratasys because
it's gonna be cheaper kind of the whole
Amazon model I still order my spinach
rather than growing my spinach at my
house so what did what do you think if
I'm like missing a button on my jacket
right what am I gonna do print it myself
or get it ordered quickly so when I was
growing up my dad told me I could have
anything I wanted as long as they made
it myself
and we spent a lot of time making stuff
it that probably has something to do
with why I became a mechanical engineer
yeah I had
CAD tools I I'm constantly designing
printing parts learning it I I'm
swimming and everything I the it I'm
fully absorbed that's me but if I didn't
have access to 3d printers I'd be doing
it with wood and plexiglass some of my
favorite materials so yeah I got a 3d
printer at home and I got tons at work
and I'm using them all the time I think
I'm gonna do that there's a huge number
of people that are gonna do that now
they're sort of the next phase uh you
know yeah and like ping was talking
about where we can we put can we you
know put 3d printers for food in
people's houses and improve their
quality of life that's a pretty that's a
pretty neat idea but but I so I think
that that 3d printing will become and it
will gain mine share from sort of the
home shopper crowd and maybe they'll be
you know fewer milling machines at home
and more 3d printers at home but that's
just a trickle down we're gonna see the
same thing in machine shops you know
stead of just having subtractive
machines we're gonna see more additive
machines making carbon fiber parts to
replace metal parts John jigs and
fixtures of just standard industrial
machines you know so so I think just
we're gonna see that for the for the
people who like to make things or it's
their job to make things more and more
additive technologies will be the
appropriate or the cool thing to do and
that's where it will be now will we all
have Star Trek replicator someday sure
but I can't connect the dots to that
right now yeah this has been an absolute
pleasure thank you so much please super
fun guys if you had a good time please
give our content to like comment
subscribe please share it with other
people let's get more people talking
about additive manufacturing and the
importance of that in our world let's
get more people talking about the
importance of surgeons practicing on
cadavers that's super cool stuff and
we'll be on very shortly right after
this with Spiros so thank you very much
for tuning in and thanks cough as our
producing partners of this event and
thanks Ron Vargas are a producing
partner in the back thank you awesome